back everyone the pandemic has created  some new uses for robots and many are  becoming more lifelike  than ever and maybe more than you'd ever  want to see this is sophia she was  created by hanson robotics back in 2016.  well they've been working on her design  ever since sophia look at that she can  talk and even carry on a conversation  she even has a range of facial  expressions and can give you a high five  eventually the hope is to use the  androids as health care aides  i will take your temperature rating and  pulse with this little thermal camera on  my chest  robots like me can help take care of the  sick or elderly  wow that looks way too real sophia is  not the only robot with a brand new job  others are being used during the  pandemic to disinfect public areas  and even deliver food in a restaurant